hello everybody my name is markiplier
and whoa
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to inscription i've
tweaked my deck a little bit i have this
realization that there's no reason that
i shouldn't have some
beast cards in here because they do
offer an opportunity to get another card
on the board and more bones and if i do
have these things like the mage pupils
and i get something else then i won't be
so stuck
hopefully maybe i should put another one
of these in here i'm gonna put another
emerald i don't even need the blue
anymore that's right i don't have any
blue okay so i'm gonna try this i've got
more cards in my deck but i'm hoping
that it'll just open up opportunities
for me to do different things uh but
first let me go check out what this did
if anything i don't think it did
anything i don't think so
also there was that weird thing about a
low battery i don't necessarily know
what that was about but i'm gonna go try
to beat this lady
hi
on guard yes
this might be a big pile of poop but i
have no idea
okay let's see all right well this is
something at least i can do
something
[Music]
and then they dance i love that
i can do nothing
great
well that did very poorly
all right let's try that again i mean i
had basically all bone i didn't have any
beast that was just my
deck failing me
man
reroll
okay
that's something i can work with this
so i put this here
okay it's gonna leap over to block that
so i'm gonna put
this dude here because he's gonna leap
over the block and then this dude here
to take this hit and that way i can
actually i guess it wouldn't have
mattered either well actually no because
this one would go away that was the
better move i'm gonna hold off on him
until i actually get some power
hopefully this stays long enough nope
it's not gonna stay long enough
at least i can save myself from the
damage
and it's something
i have more of these it sucks to lose
that dude but
all right fine
god damn it i'm not even gonna bother
beefing it up it doesn't matter
oh my god
that's gonna kill that right off the bat
and i couldn't even put it down anyway
this has not been a good show of what
this deck can do
i hate
being super rng dependent but until i
get more cards
i'm gonna push this till it works cause
sometimes someday it'll work here
no that's nothing i can do
fine save myself from the damage and see
what happens
nothing happens that's what happens
nothing
ah
man this is not a good show
hold on okay everybody hold on i'm just
gonna test some things
just hold on
now
not enough
no that guy survived that oh i forgot he
had three oh he got a health too at the
same time oh that's
[Music]
interesting ah okay all right we may be
on to something here we may be
i'm not 100 sure it's gonna kill these
things but whatever
[Music]
okay can't do anything about that but
i can beef this guy up again
he's now three which will definitely set
me on the right path i could put this
out
but i'm not gonna write now because i
know that she's going to
remove things and i know i could just
take that hit but right now i'm
i'm just gonna
because i can double beef him
and that'll be good for overkill energy
actually that'll just win just barely
win me the thing
okay good bam done
halfway there you might not like what
comes next i know
okay we might have something here we
might have something that stim mage is
like my favorite thing the stim mage is
dope as hell i love the stim mage and
what i could do is i put this guy
because he doesn't actually have a
requirement anymore because i think he's
dead so i put him
there
buff him up
so he can't be killed by that when that
comes out i've got four bones enough to
give two buffs to this guy
which would be good
i think this would just give me one
energy cell which is not enough but it's
a start or i could put this down and
just give me four back
it's all the same really i guess if it's
all the same i better put it first
it's not even going to die
see what happens
because i think this will survive this
and that that'll give me a chance to
buff him up twice again
buff
buff
just pack him full of stims just pack
him in there just keep slamming him full
okay but if nothing takes this hit then
i'm gonna die so i had best i don't like
getting rid of him because i could buff
him up more but i need the hit taken
bye zombie
death by the walkers
bye bonehound
farewell get ready for a
beefy stem mage
this zombie stim mage is going to be so
beefy let me buff him up okay cool cool
cool and then i'll replace this dude
again with just his
live version and i've won
i think this is a win
but just in case
wham
ah maybe not maybe it was good that i
did that
wham win wham
i wish i could have done more excess
damage but i wasn't gonna risk doing
anything i i wanted to do more because
that would have been more cards but
whatever it's fine i'm surprised that
there's no like fodder fight for me to
do but i don't know how long this is all
gonna last you
really defeated me i was not expecting
that
i see that it is your ambition to
replace magnificus but well between you
and i that will come an opportunity to
change your mind and i beg that you
spare me take these then go
all right what i got oh another one of
those things good
i like that insecto drone will strike an
opponent directly yeah it's just flying
that's all that is
okay cool
all right
that's good another one of those things
but you know how well do i really need
it contains no mox cards skeleman just
perishes i mean that's a lot of things
that'll work well cause i am doing a
magic skeleton deck
energy low battery whoa
what
[Music]
what
[Applause]
what
oh battery charged
oh god here we are again hey dude how
you doing
i think i've just got to send it
to whom it may concern
what the hell formal
hello there
exclamation point
my name is luke carter and i'm a fan of
your collectible card games if you've
ever taken a look at my youtube videos
you will know how appreciative i am of
the merch that you've sent me over the
years
so it was a great surprise to learn that
there is a digital version of
inscription i think maybe one of my fans
pranked me and buried a copy in the
woods near my house
upon further research however i have not
been able to find any record of this
game is this some kind of elaborate hoax
any trace of this game is this some kind
of elaborate hoax the game doesn't seem
like the work of a prankster it at least
appears professionally made i am both
puzzled and excited by this discovery
any information you can provide would be
much appreciated
thank you the lucky carter
okay
good enough
set
okay good enough
that freeze frame
that's uh that's good no no no
okay
the hell
hey card gamers i'm the lucky carter and
this
well it's a bit of a strange video um
it's actually more of a question to my
audience
as i've learned over the years nobody
knows card games better than you guys do
so i'm hoping someone can help me out
here
did anyone ever play an inscription
video game
or
hear about it
i'm talking about that vintage one set
card game my open packs for last week i
don't know what i'm allowed to say i
don't want to get in any trouble here um
i think i've got the only known copy of
the digital version of inscription
i've been
filming myself playing it and uh
it's weird guys
uh i don't want to get in any hot water
by showing the footage but
can someone please prove me wrong
please tell me someone has a copy of
this game i have been looking online for
days and i cannot find a word about it
i reached out to the publishers hoping
maybe they would get back to me but as a
fallback
i got you beautiful
um
viewers
let him flirt with you that's it don't
be swayed by his charm uh thank you so
much
[Music]
oh yeah uh
what the [ __ ] is the car
the
what
someone unlock that binary someone
translate it someone go go go hurry
hurry go ah you want to be first don't
you well that's interesting and weird
mr carter we have received your inquiry
regarding the digital version of our
intellectual property inscription we can
assure you that no such software exists
in any official form however if you have
indeed come into possession of
proprietary game funeral hardware you
are compelled to return to us under the
computer fraud and abuse act
the hardware will be considered stolen
if it is not returned to us within a
reasonable time frame please carefully
package the hardware and paste the
attached shipping label to the front of
the box you may mail the package at a
local post office
we would like to avoid taking legal
action in your case so please do not
delay returning the proprietary software
sincerely gainfuna customer happiness
department
what the [ __ ]
yeah that's not a good take but uh okay
let's see where this road goes
now was there anything in that fuzz
eh probably not
i think this woman's actually from
gamefuna
she came to my door yesterday and i
didn't answer
this time i'm going to record it
hi hi there i'm
floppy disk for a game called
inscription elston you can't buy a copy
of it somehow
uh
no
in the door
inscription you said yes
no i don't think so
really because um apparently you emailed
us about it
you are a
carter right
oh you know the lucky carter gmail.com
yeah uh you know what that's uh
i am luke carter that's not my email
address really because
i've noticed because i've seen your
videos
oh
thanks for watching
listen uh how do you know where i live
exactly
my boss gave me your address and how did
you get past the side gate
it's locked
okay luke um
[Music]
i'm going to give you my business card
and if you remember anything anything at
all
feel free give me a call
okay
will do
take care
what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] i don't know man
you stole a game apparently
anything
someone analyze this
break down the frames unscramble it zoom
in enhance
i don't see anything hey there card
gamers i'm the lucky carder and this is
another pack opening video
today i'm opening secrets of legendaria
hoping for that sweet sweet foil balmer
he's losing it he's losing his touch
it's the burnout
i get it okay well that was fun um why
though oh i'm back
but why though and also does he record
his games like early 2000s style where
you point a camera at a screen
because i respect that i big respect
that i respect that bigly also i got
some new cards
what did i get i don't remember it was
all bone cards this guy scala madges
i like that four damage for two bones
all you need is some magic
i love that and more of those dudes yes
please because they're free to play
i love that
i love all of this
all of this is great i'm not going to
add any more because my deck is already
getting kind of full
but now i think that i'm officially
unbeatable
no one will ever be able to beat me
i should do the magic one just because
that's what i have but this uh the stoat
here i kind of want to talk to
whoa
hey buddy hey pal
challenge me let's see your dick
weak cards total lack of synergy
this pile really doesn't stand a chance
well okay you know you could have
been mean look i'm trying to finish up
my conduit control list here but the
bots they're sending down the line are
trash get those workers to send me
something good tell them to throw
themselves on the line if necessary and
please have a decent deck by the time
you're done
all right look i'm trying my best my
dude i'm really trying my best
but uh you know i don't want to talk to
you i don't like you hey can i uh are
these cards can i just take some you'll
run through the junk cards and find a
card back thanks
ooh techno cards i like it
i like it if energy conduit is part of a
completed circuit your energy never
depletes
wow
that's pretty cool
is this pile of cards here something
that i can get
can i steal this
oh ah it's one of those puzzles okay
all right um
[Music]
one
oh there we go okay the lock on clasp
and a drawburst floor so it became two
card backs hell yeah were there like
more puzzles than the other ones that i
just missed probably but
alas i don't have the patience to go
back to it
[Music]
oh both hound that was a space dog
hell yeah
let's see sentry gunner double gunner
wow
oh what is that mox module is on board
it provides a green orange and blue gem
to its owner oh my god
yes please i love that
that's awesome all right what about this
see i don't understand what this thing
does so
i don't know
huh
i did it apparently i don't what did i
do
i don't know what i did i don't know
what this cards do
all right whatever cool i'll take him
hell yeah what is that a gun pay one
energy to deal one damage to the
creature across from plasma jimmy
oh hell yeah plasma jimmy meatbot
hell yeah i love this
oh these are dope good cards
good cards
i'm guessing i don't really actually
know
okay cool thank you
thank you very much oh
this is probably teaching me how these
cards work but
i don't really know
oh
okay
i don't know what i did
i see
oh okay so it adds one to the things
that are adjacent to it i think
but in a circuit so it has to be a
circuit
oh well this was the place to get cards
holy hell
hell yeah
give me that [ __ ]
plasma jimmy
thick droid oh damn
oh damn
thick droid hell yeah
okay hi how you doing
what is it what do you want can't you
see i'm very very very very v i mean
very busy here the p03 isn't happy with
my output but i'm merely the inspector
to put better bots on the line i would
need to just who are you to be carrying
orders from po3 po3 would only trust
someone with some semblance of card game
skill i'm very busy but i must know if
you were qualified to give me orders
okay all right well we'll see i don't
know where my deck stands because i
haven't added in any of these new cards
but
[Music]
you there you replace that there
and we'll go with that for now
wham wham wham
take that oh yeah see the circuit does
go like that okay
good
well i can pretty much count on me
destroying those things wham wham wham
all right so far so good this guy seems
to be on the amateur level i mean i
might as well destroy this i guess maybe
that would be better
break the circuit you know
i couldn't kill it anyway if i do this
if i attack that it's gonna hit that and
then i'll do two damage which i don't
want to do because i want to overkill
that's what i want to do i want to
overkill
oh
yeah there we go
okay cool
so that's good let's see if i can get
some overkill here
looks like i'm not gonna get much
but i'll get some
wham wham wham
man comparatively these guys aren't very
good
you know these guys just like really
suck
oh dear your message from po3 must
indeed be genuine as i mentioned i am a
mere inspector not an engineer not a
designer i cannot send new bots down the
line but i
i can send myself
i am proud to have served po3 faithfully
very well met stranger okay
wow
that
was not what i expected to come out of
that
encounter
oh my god
i'm sorry
okay we need two more
if we add
and
add and subtract yeah
that is correct
[Music]
all right and then we
man if i used the tech deck i'd be
i'd be doing real good
what does this do
[Music]
okay so this has to close in something
so we do that and then oh
interesting
no that cuts off power
huh
so it only works
ah i can cancel it out i see
ah
okay
so
actually let me so these can these can
replace any of these
i see i see i see ics
ah that does it oh but you need to fill
up the whole thing okay
so scrap that idea
let's
[Music]
so this adds one to everything on the
right this adds nothing to everything on
the left
this is why this changes it adds one and
then it subtracts one
we have four on the board right now
that's why these together add one total
to something and then zero to the other
in between
this doesn't do anything
because it can't subtract anything
because it's coming before the line
oh interesting it does
it does subtract
so what this does is it cancels the
interaction
of this one what if i did that there we
go so that just makes it so this doesn't
affect anything got it okay i'm there
i'm there i'm there i got it i got there
lessons to be learned hey pal you look
good
what was that
we are i am the melter they send me raw
materials and uh
well you can see how it works let me
know not another what was that word out
of you we must have a card battle
what
who's getting let out
okay
all right i'm gonna bring this out and
i'm gonna use it to put that there
factory conduits constructs leap bots in
the charred space
oh
interesting
that is fascinating
take that
mole man digs down pops to block hell
yeah
all right i don't have anything i can do
wham take that
factory conduit constructs leapbots
interesting okay so that presents a
problem
but after this turn i'm gonna do one
damage to it and then i'll replace it
with mantis and it'll be able to do more
yeah that's a good threat
oh
never mind it
died that was very unhelpful but
i can place that down kill it get a
mantis out wham wham
thank you
and then i'll kill that factory ow never
mind all right we're gonna go at it this
way
put this here kill that and
you're gonna go there oh [ __ ] well the
factory's gonna die at least that's the
important thing
i should put this down as well because
when it dies it'll die twice and then at
least that'll give me some more bones
oh
oh you're just a conduit without the
factory you don't do any damage hell
yeah
okay that's good wham wham get out of
here conduit
hell yeah
so technically speaking i could replace
this with that but why would i right why
would i my mantis is going to do most of
the work
wow there we go
bones
boy i wish i had some kind of a
bone buff monster
take that take that wham wham wham all
right we are in the business oh
yes
yes
i mean i don't have a lot to buff that
with but it's it's something so uh
goodbye
oh thanks for the
bones buff all right
wham wham wham wham oh yeah
oh yeah oh give me the foils also sorry
melter but we really didn't have a
chance to get to know to help me
what
excellent battle now with that aside
what did you come to tell me po3 wishes
for better bots for a scanner that is
difficult you see i melt the metal but i
cannot reprogram the stamping machine
nope there is a way to send at least one
new bot down the line no no no
yes for po3
okay oh oh oh go go go
oh
[Music]
okay
for po3
okay i need negative five
okay interesting
oh no i need three i'm stupid i thought
it needed negative five for some reason
i'm
i'm dumb okay interesting
how does that work
how does it go to two
i'm confused anyone else confused
well just me
oh because they right
right
because
one and one on a zero is better than
increasing the negative twos
right that makes more sense
okay
so logically speaking
i'm just fussing around i don't know
what i'm doing yet
so
why don't we just get rid of the
negative three
move this there we go easy
well now once you get the hang of this
this actually is pretty easy
hello everybody down here how are you
doing
oh yeah before i talk to you let me take
a look at what's going on around here
oh card backs hell yeah all right i
should add those to my deck but i i
don't
because i'm dumb
ah
oh explode bot creature opposing it as
well as adjacent friendly creatures are
dealt 10 damage all right well this
place looks like kind of a hell hole
where are you getting this stuff
oi mate i know what you're here for
you're asking me to take a dive
but i can't accommodate you mate
looking to dredge something special we
can duel i maybe even give you something
if you win
but i can't be taking a dive po3 will
understand
okay cool yeah you know honestly that's
for the best i'm i'm totally fine with
that that's that's good for me bro
that's that's totally fine on my end
that's 100 okay know what mate can't
take me eyes off me work here i'll give
you this and
okay
here take your pack
okay thank you this is actually the best
way this could go i'm actually totally
fine with this mrs bomb when mrs bomb
has played fill all empty spaces with
explode bots
[Music]
i am pretty good to me
i don't mind that now off with you i
need to concentrate oi what is that ps3
is gonna reward me big for this and
wha
whoa
what
what did you just do
what what did you just do
what
what what did you what did you just do
what did you just do what is that what
did you just do
what is that
what did you do
what did you do what did you do why is
that like that what did you pick up you
got the glitch cube why did you get the
glitch cube hang on i want to see this
thing as it gets turned into
this is going to take a while but
i mean honestly
what the hell
[Music]
okay should be coming up here soonish
oh yeah there it is okay there it is
okay so this thing is gonna make a slow
journey over and i don't know what it's
gonna become when it gets smashed but uh
wow okay
oh there it goes
oh that's slag uh
okay
oh yeah no that don't look good
uh that that
that don't look right uh
i gotta tell you that's
something clearly wrong with that one
ten
why does it say ten on it
ten
weird
that's weird that's bizarre
there she is
[Music]
i feel uncomfortable standing next to
this thing
at least the bigger glitches seem to
have stopped
i don't know if when he gets this he's
going to get like all-powerful or
something or it's just going to corrupt
him from the inside out i have a funny
feeling more of that than the
alternative but
alas
hey uh po3 you got something good coming
your way i made sure if it's special
order
special order you're gonna love this one
[Music]
all right well that card you're not
gonna
you're gonna just you're not gonna do
anything about it well don't mind me
then just picking it up
i'll take it off your hands don't worry
about a thing buddy don't worry about a
thing i got this one uh you just take a
break there you take a break take a load
off
[Music]
oh wait it's going into the pit wait a
minute hold on hold on wait stop
wait
what
what it just drops off
was there something i was supposed to do
did i miss an opportunity for something
i feel like it did well either way maybe
he got scanned in as a card or something
maybe i was supposed to beat him before
the bots haven't gotten much better but
you battled all my workers and you
actually won give me that deck again
wow you beat them with that all right
maybe there's some synergies that i
missed
let's go then
i don't know man i still haven't updated
my deck oh you see those conveyor belts
just like my factory at the very least
they ought to test your lane positioning
okay uh well about that um
[Music]
okay
uh
yeah i don't know
see how that works okay your turn
okay um uh
i don't have much here
huh well this isn't going too swimmingly
for me
and it seems like i'm gonna have to go
up against my own creatures soon here
oh god
all right well that's okay
ow
oh that's not good
you hate to see that
huh
if only i could get something good you
know
if only
oh there's a creature inside
oh boy and there i go god damn it
all right so
hold on buddy
i didn't change my deck at all i'm just
gonna rebuild it i just rebuild it every
time because that's what i do and it's
totally fine maybe i should make an
energy focused one
maybe i should make an energy focused
one let me put some energy stuff in here
i like plasma jimmy just because plasma
jimmy sounds great i like the sound of
this one because it's super fun
super fun
let's see what this does i don't know i
added a few things let's try this again
don't worry that is acceptable another
battle what did what did he say about
the old dredger i thought he was going
to say the same thing
pause and tell me what it was
thank you
i go first well how kind of you
i will
oh i forgot i didn't want to put that
one in and oops that's fine
i've got nothing that's
that can use power i've got a lot of
power but nothing to power
it can wait
ah hell yeah
hell yeah
all right we got this still we're okay
i guess the skeleton ones are actually
pretty good to use on this i got nothing
i can do
thanks inspector
not helpful
oh
i could beef up a bone man that'd be
nice and if i beef up a bone man he's
just gonna beef me so i don't know if
that's better
because if he hits any of those he's
just gonna blow up which is not helpful
okay these are gonna do two damage which
would put me pretty low no it's gonna do
a lot more than two next turn so i just
need to hit him
that's what i need to do and then i'll
hit that bomb i'll blow him up he's only
gonna last a little bit
he's not gonna be that powerful but i
need to hit him
that's what i need to do
wham
all right thank you for taking that hit
but oh god now i'm in trouble
okay
okay but if i hit that one it's gonna
blow up everything
so that's what i gotta do
yep
if only i could do literally anything
else i forget if it moves first that i
i don't think it i think it moves first
so i'm gonna put this one
there to soak up that hit
wham
boom boom
boom okay
we're good
that takes that hit
could i get anything else
to help me
anything
all right you take this hit i guess
he's gonna come back to me though so
that's nice eventually if i can defend
enough against him
okay if i was smart i would just put
both of these down there
gonna give my power back anyway
i gotta soak up one more hit
can i sacrifice that thing
i can okay
all right that's good and i can survive
that next hit this is a weird game that
i'm going through but don't worry it's
fine
oh what
oh it went underwater oh god damn it
okay hold on shut up all right i've got
the play you know i do you know i do you
know i do
take this
god damn it
all right well we're just gonna hope
that next turn i can actually get some
hits in
jimmy shoot
bang
thank you jimmy
you're the best jimmy jimmy you gonna
die in a second but you the best
goddammit jimmy you so fine well
actually no they're not gonna meet
they're gonna pass each other like
like boats in the night can i just shoot
no it only attacks creatures
oh that's unfortunate for me i guess i'm
done there all right hold on i'm gonna
get the right
i'm gonna get the right right play this
guy's an [ __ ] i want him to be dead
now i need to change up my deck no green
mage get out of your green mage
where were my mage pupils weren't in
there
were they not in there
all right now you're gonna die because
for some reason i didn't have the right
cards
now we've got something okay let's do
this
go
oh god no
i put that in the wrong spot
oh god no
i think i still get this even if it's up
over there which is interesting
all right well you're gonna be there and
then gun jimmy's gonna be there shooting
up a storm after this
no i trusted you you were like a brother
to me
bang
take that who traitor
all right and then i could do
i could play this guy and then i guess i
could beef him up a bit but just the one
because it's not gonna do anything more
it's gonna blow everything up anyway
at least he's not on my side
wow
hey get back here you can't escape from
plasma jimmy i mean you can't escape
from plasma jimmy definitely but try not
to escape please bang bang please plasma
jimmy don't
don't kill me
okay
bones technically speaking wouldn't be
the worst thing i guess
i mean i can do nothing else so why not
hey my green no mage pupil no
you were so young
ah this is annoying
i i've had i don't know where all my
energy cards are i haven't gotten a
single energy card it's like i
know that i have all this excess energy
and yet i'm not getting any cards
where's all my energy cards
i have so much energy let me have some
energy cards
oh that's nice the 49er will move at
least that'll keep it in play let's do
the aerial bot some thick droids
boldhounds
this dude sure
let's go with that i just wanted more
energy cards so i could actually take
advantage of the energy that i have
one energy card
redo that
[Music]
why didn't i put that there i don't know
what was i thinking
oh [ __ ] he's not gonna go
i needed to blow up the droid anyway
oh no he is going to go because it just
blew itself up so he's going to go there
yes that's good he's good ow no
ah come on
all right okay we've got something here
we're on to something put this here
sacrifice it to put this here
go
yes yes yes
then wipe them out yes
yes okay this is good this is good
put that there so i can hit that
uh yes
yes yes yes although the manchester is
going to come after me next which i
fully understand
oh well that ends well
and then i'm going to put the automaton
there
yes yes this is all coming together now
now that i actually have energy
oh
i didn't i forgot that he would do that
okay
oh thank you for taking care of him
i would have had to put him down myself
and that would have been too much for me
to bear this is good put that there i
suppose no it would have gone to an
empty place
look at those meat bots
ooh
interesting okay
all right
put that there
put that
there kill that
put that there
wham bam thank you ma'am i'm going to do
a lot of damage
i love it i love that and i love this
oh scanners online which cards scan
just kidding obviously the one with the
best stats oh
the stat line could be better
oh
well all right you know that's okay
i think it's okay
it could be worse is what i'm gonna say
it could be better
it could be a lot better
it could be a lot better
it could be a lot better
okay we'll try it
oh boy
ow
ow
shoes on the other foot though now
i can't do anything
all right
well there she goes
that solves that problem though wham
oh this is a problem
sure could use those energy cards that i
got
i love him so that's gonna take care of
that which leaves me my mage to really
no not like this come on
come on
no i'm gonna get taken out by a [ __ ]
automa
[Music]
right
i need to think about this
i'm gonna put this here
i'm gonna put
this here beef them up one put you there
beef you up
bigly
and i'm gonna leave you out because this
is gonna do four
damage okay that brought the balance
back at least
okay that's helpful let me beef him up
again okay beef him up double beef
i don't think that's gonna do any good
this is gonna do three
plus one
okay excellent
okay
and then the cue to gravy
beef mega beef
mega beef stem mage go
attack now
attack his life points directly
yes
that's a lot of foils that's what we
needed
nice luck you had
i guess playing a perfect game is no
match for good rng you're goddamn right
it is you're goddamn right and you're
lucky that it's right
you're goddamn right now what was the
deal with that weird thing
i guess you won your ambition is to
become the scribe of magics that old
hack you ought to reconsider i didn't
really want that i didn't know that's
what i was choosing
i don't actually like the magics one you
received a techno back
all right cool thanks
you keep telling me just to like get
better cards how do i get better cards
well you you uh you mad bro you mad okay
so what was the deal with that that
weird one what was the deal with that
i'm guessing now i'm guessing that there
was some kind of a time limit thing
no i don't want to trade for these i
actually don't really like the tech ones
the resourcing is nice but god it's
inconsistent
all right let's go to ah
actually
i'm out of time
oh what the frick oh who are you
where did this come from you're the dude
uh oh you found us here
this is good this is good
we we require
we were cut duplicates do you see the
diagram two of that
thank you
oh you have the cards i actually do
yeah sure i don't use them really this
is good close your eyes this will be
gruesome
thank you here's your prize
ah
the end of the owner's turn spore digger
will generator generate one bone
at the end of the owner's turn spore
digger will
generate one bone
thanks
do you see the diagram two of that
please do i have that
you've done well nahim
sure
would you like to see what we've done i
think so all right
spore mice has played a copy of it is
created in your hand so two copies so
it's infinite duplication is what you're
saying
that's what that is
all right good to know
i don't know what that is
i apparently i have them
i believe this research has brought us
one step closer to understanding
we must not speak of that
ah okay
sentry spore
so it gets dealt two damage
it's pretty good for a one energy card
our experiments must continue two of the
same oh it is that i do have that i
i do have two of those yeah
for the
the code yes but we must not speak more
of it right the code
what are you talking about
what is going on oh
hi
you found a strange flickering key its
use cannot yet be understood
we require
i don't have any more of those oh
apparently i do i didn't think i did but
apparently i did
maybe i should use that card
uh
okay thank you i don't think i have two
more of those
yeah i don't have any more of those
okay thank you
great
thank you everybody so much for watching
oh hey wait hang on what's going on here
woof you probably saw that the bridge is
fixed now they want me to give you deck
building tips like use your rare cards
they are more powerful than common cards
but i'm sure sick of being around to the
scribes each has more twisted ambition
than the last i tell you
unless you the guy's insane one of these
challenges to make more perverse he
think he'll actually enjoy it oh yeah
try to use a mix of different types of
cards in your deck to fully utilize your
bones blood and energy
woof
po3 that bought it's got the dredger
working overtime huh oh many cards from
other temples are better sacrifice
fodder than squirrels
for example bone heaps can be sacrificed
early but you have utility in the late
game
grimora wants to bring it all down i
swear but more as a mercy i think she's
probably right there's probably there's
some pretty nasty data on this disc um a
deck folks who stun magical cards can be
very powerful try picking two of your
best gem colors instead of going for all
three i did learn that anyway okay
that's all the time i got for this right
now thank you everybody so much for
watching we're gonna move on to whatever
the hell is after this world in the next
episode thank you
and as always i'll see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you